aujourd'hui il ya quelques mesures
concrètes
mais ce qui manque quand même
incontestablement c'est la ligne
directrice
on voit bien ce havre de mesures sur le
logement soit fiscalité sur lies avait
calé jeudi après je regrette je le dis
franchement pas ce que je vous souhaite
et légaliste les utilisateurs dans les
discours mais on entend assez peu parler
de la france
on a pensé peut parler de la nation on
n'a pas assez préparé la république est
là on voit bien on a bien que des
mesures ici ou là mais bon me dit on va
défendre les territoires ruraux qui doit
être plus précis demain et venir parler
c'est ce que j'espère je passe qu'à
réalité demain et de philippe qui sait
qu'au sénat n'a pas de majorité
établissez le moins qu'on puisse dire a
peut-être de mettre un peu plus précis
un peu plus percutant un peu plus
concret parce que là pour le moment
bon là les menus koné qu'est ce qu'on va
faire
qu'est-ce qu'on fait dur
on se déteste cet été au delà on va pas
bien la ligne était quels sont les
objectifs du regard ce que nous dit on
veut rendre les français pour
d'un gouvernement qui vient faire un
éclat son petit frère c'est vous soyez
tous malheureux comme peu de mon chrono
donc il faut des choses plus en plus
précises savoir comment on y arrive dans
quelles conditions comment ce que le
gouvernement autres avec le parlement
ait pas eu un mot là-dessus
et pas un mot sur comment on va
travailler ensemble ce qu'on est
susceptible de travailler ensemble
puisqu'une gouvernement veut tout faire
directement sans le parlement on ne sait
pas alors j'espère que demain sur simple
pression